[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 58 i am
alerted
58 live dark horse podcasts
in a row uh right in a row right almost
immediately in a row if you count only
the live ones
yes yeah that's circular but let's just
go
so uh a very happy hanukkah
to you all hanukkah is ongoing i
remember maybe you remember
you and i both grew up in la obviously
do you remember our local stations
had a broadcast during hanukkah and they
would say
happy hanukkah to our jewish friends
do you remember that i don't remember
that no i remember i
felt like is that a threat i mean it
seems friendly but there was just a
little
stationary talking about like i don't
know it was uh
i think it was all of the local ones had
some version of that
okay um to our jewish friends exactly
and the thing is
because you couldn't see the person
saying it you didn't know if they were
raising an eyebrow which of course tells
you whether it's to be taken ironically
you're talking about radio stations
no no this was television i think it was
just they had an image
of a menorah i don't know what it was
and then the voice over would say that
sure
or possibly i imagined it that's why i
was hoping that you might have
remembered it as well
i don't know i guess but you know it
wasn't targeted me i wasn't one of their
jewish friends exactly
exactly so yes it would have been less
significant i would imagine
yeah so this does raise a question
though i was wondering
why is it that uh
energizer is not the official battery of
hanukkah
you were wondering this i was wondering
this yesterday was that it's been
plaguing you while you're out on your
nighttime midnight bike ride yeah in
december
chilly chilly chilly bike ride chilly
but dry and you're wondering
why energizer batteries are not the
official battery of hanukkah
is there an official anything of
hanukkah no
but were i energizer i would at least
note that you could
avail yourself of something like you
know the slogan
it's like maccabee lamp oil but for
electronic stuff
or something along those lines you see
what i'm saying
mm-hmm yeah i think there's a reason you
didn't go into this lineup
advertising yes that's that's possible
yeah i would have been um atrocious at
it
to say the least yes yes yes although i
mean i
so we wanted to start out and i don't
like uh pivoting this way but
um you do come up with pithy sayings
like your algorithm is no good here
and uh we are beginning to have them
available on things like
uh hoodies and shirts and such so
anyone who's interested can go wherever
whatever that
site is it is called
uh store.darkhorsepodcast.org
yes to get such things if you are so
interested at least
one person on twitter thought that uh
your confirmation bias is not my problem
was also a slogan worthy of a shirt now
i don't know
if it's worth it for one person but it's
possible that they speak for a multitude
your comfort your confirmation bias is
not my problem also
seeing interest in first against the
wall club the first against the wall
club of course
that could be a beautiful shirt yeah
yeah um
yes and i don't know how we ended up on
this we actually created an intro screen
actually zach created it though i'm
going to take credit on all of our
behalf
um the he created an intro screen that
is supposed to free us from talking
about things like merchandise
by saying it in text without us having
to
sully ourselves by saying it out loud
except the many more than half of the
people who
um encounter this podcast only in audio
form don't see that well but they could
infer it
you see what i'm saying they couldn't
they could read they could listen
between the lines
i see yeah so um actually here i just
accidentally have this
on the desk here this came for us um
and i was privileging the youtube
viewers aren't you i am oh yes
so for those of you listening uh on
audio only versions
what i have here is uh a dark horse
coffee mug
and um i was skeptical at first but i
tried it
works great holds coffee yeah i mean
your joke but the thing is there are
thousands of ways an object like this
can fail and there's only a few it can
work and this one threads the needle it
works great
you're speaking to a ceramicist so yeah
i'm quite aware of how many ways
a mug can fail yeah they usually yeah
they they can fail a lot of ways a lot
of them when they're still before
they're uh
they're dried yeah you want to get them
up to the uh
the cone that both the clay body and the
glaze are derived for
totally devised four created for i did
also
um i invented a new drink using this oh
boy
no i did um what you do it looks very
dry
it's not here now in fact i'm it's not
here in part because i don't want us to
get
demonetized um oh right what kind of
drink is it
does it in fact have mrna in it
we'll get there no um what you do is you
take you take the glass you put it on a
flat surface it's a mug
uh you load it with about an
ounce of i used rum i think it would
work with tequila
probably would work with vodka i don't
know if it would work
with scotch or whiskey because i'm
allergic to wheat and therefore don't
touch those things but it might
so anyway on the flat surface you put a
an ounce of rum in there so super
innovative so far
and then you drink it and it's called oh
a portland mug shot
all right okay um yeah so that that that
could have been worse
you know actually i used to give you
points i used to give him points yes
yes yes that's the thing is it's
wonderful
uh when one's wife will actually award
points for a good joke that's a great
thing but when the scale goes negative
it can go wrong
mighty quickly so quickly so yeah i'll
give you seven points for that one
that's not bad in my experience that's
pretty good all right
portland mugshot a portland mug shot yep
i feel that was worth it
all right so today we want to talk a bit
about vaccines
uh well we feel compelled to talk about
vaccines i can't say that i actually
want to talk about vaccines but we
compel
we feel compelled to talk a bit about
vaccines um
you had some things to say about uh
journalism and the media uh we wanted to
talk a little bit about
uh some observations about traffic
and uh if we have time a little bit
about sexy flies
totally i am very much looking forward
to that part of the conversation because
i
i'm finding it hard to imagine a sexy
fly oh you're not talking about spanish
flies are you
no no all right then i can't figure out
what that would be in reference to so
i'm in suspense like the rest of you
terrific
all right um so yes i will just say that
i
this may be a me thing but i feel that i
am being driven
slowly crazy by the conversation
surrounding vaccines generally
coronavirus vaccines specifically
the ongoing pandemic and where we are
and
might be and all of those things and
as those who have been around for the
last couple of live streams now
i also feel a certain amount of jeopardy
around discussing these things because
there is this absolutely oppressive
authoritarian
nanny voice that belongs to the tech
platforms
where they somehow
believe that they are in a position to
know what is true and who may voice what
kind of skepticism when
one cannot look up these things there's
no phone number you can call and ask
is it permissible to discuss this even
though i don't believe that they should
be in a position to say it is or it
isn't i'd at least like to know
whether or not we are putting the
channel in danger by doing so but i
don't i
increasingly just don't think we have a
choice i think
um you uh we are in a position to
discuss it responsibly and it must be
done
in spite of the fact that there are
risks in that discussion
um they are not uh they do not justify
censoring
such discussions yeah uh let me just as
one piece of evidence that there are
risks here that the the dominant
narrative sounds a particular way
um is it's sort of one of scolding and
tutting
and how could you be so dim as to
believe these things
here zachary is a
thing from bbc news called reality check
from the 2nd of december called vaccine
rumors debunked microchips altered dna
and more and we have we've talked about
things like this in different contexts
where
um some um some batshit conspiracy
hypothesis
like the lizard people are among us
right
uh is mixed in with things that are not
mainstream
but that should be plausibly considered
right so
um we have here for instance in this in
this list
um the fear that a vaccine will somehow
change your dna
um injecting rna into a person doesn't
do anything to the dna of a human cell
says professor almond of oxford
university that's true
uh we don't this as far as we know
an mrna vaccine has no access to
the dna as far as we know yes
bill gates and microchip claims this
does seem absurd and it has seemed
absurd from the beginning
fetal tissue claims i have no idea
i there's no reason there's no reason
given what kind of vaccine this is for
them ever to have engaged any fetal
tissue
at all and then
just the last one on this list i think
uh recovery rate claims
well um we actually don't
know how to assess recovery rates
unless all we're looking at is death
versus not death
and this is something that we talked
about a lot in the first whatever it was
16 17 18 episodes
of this live stream yes and uh as we you
know
of the many things that we have said
that i think constitute
a better model than the one publicly
being discussed in some cases the
uh the public model has caught up and in
some many places it hasn't
but um the right way to think of it
is how much life does
being sick with uh the coronavirus
rob you of right and the answer is very
likely to be a substantial number of
years which means even if you
uh appear to have recovered what we know
about the tissue damage that comes
with this thing suggests that that you
didn't die
is not evidence that you got away with
it it is evidence that
um there you had a buffer um so anyway
people should be very much aware of that
all right and we have
um this because it would this would play
through my computer i'm not going to
show it because it won't
you won't guys won't be able to hear it
um but when the uk
approved for the first time ever as a as
a hell as a major health agency an mrna
vaccine whatever this was last week i
guess
um what the regulator-in-chief
said was quote the benefits far outweigh
any risk
and this is this is what you would say
if you were
heading up an agency that had just
decided to
to go forward with this but there is no
way that anyone can plausibly say that
at this point because we cannot know
right we cannot know what all the risks
are i would never
utter a statement like that you might
say if you wanted to say that statement
in a way that it was perfectly
defensible
you might say the benefits outweigh
any known harm right by putting it in
the context of risk they are saying
something insane and indefensible
yeah and actually i i thought we might
wrap up with this but maybe before you
launch into what you're gonna launch
into um it occurred to me that there are
at least four questions
that we should be asking about about
any treatment really but in this case
it's about a vaccine how
safe is it quite aside from how
effective it is
how effective is it quite aside from how
safe it is
what are the risks from contracting
covet 19 not just the death rates by age
etc but the long-term health effects and
for this third question we cannot know
all of those answers nor can we
even nor for that first question can we
know all of the long-term safety answers
but given those first two questions
safety not
efficacy efficacy not safety and
also the actual risks from the disease
that you would be being vaccinated
against
given the answers to those first three
questions um
how do we then generate an answer to
should an individual take the vaccine
should whole populations take the
vaccine under what circumstances should
it be allowed to be a personal choice
and under what circumstances should it
be a top-down move
by a government that says actually in
order to participate in
school for instance you're going to need
to take this vaccine because we know we
have
we we have diseases like that for which
those
those decisions have been made yeah i
love that list that matrix is an
excellent one for discussing it and i
would just point out that one thing that
is very clear
if you look at that matrix is that wow
do we not know a lot about
the uh harm of coven 19 right but
boy do we know a hell of a lot more
about covet 19 than we know about these
vaccines
and the reason is because we have had
exposure
to the consequences of covet 19 for a
longer period of time than this vaccine
has been administered
to human beings so we see something
more of you know a time series what
develops
six months out for example right and the
other thing
is a much larger population has been
exposed
so to the extent to the disease then to
the vaccine right there are tail risks
and things we're in a much better
position to see them and to understand
what they look like and so uh in some
sense
you are in a decent position to
calibrate
you have any any individual we all
together collectively are in a much
better position
to calibrate how we feel the risks
associated with covid19
stack up than we are with respect to the
vaccine right
and that is a key thing because at the
same time that you know
vastly more about this disease you don't
know nearly enough
right we don't know whether or not
people who have recovered from covet 19
have
this is plausible in my opinion have
been robbed on average of 10 years of
youth right that is to say they are 10
years closer to death all things being
equal
they are their tissues it could be
particular tissues or it could be very
general
that there has been destruction and so
they have been advanced
in their senescence profile and i would
say this is something that we should be
asking for every disease
right the model that we typically walk
around with
um where you get the flu and you get
over it and you think well the cost was
you know a week or a week and then some
some lagging symptoms or something like
that the answer is no you were you were
robbed of things you don't know about
because that's the nature of tissue
damage
we can say the same thing for uh broken
limbs i mean i think people intuit this
with respect to joint damage if you
physically damage a joint you know that
there's only so many times you can put
it back together
um but you know the same goes for a
broken wrist right you're expending some
of your lifetime capacity to repair
uh to repair that damage and the chances
that your
the fact that you've advanced the age of
your wrist bones a little bit
is going to be critical is very very low
but um but nonetheless that's the model
we should be using for
anything that does damage to the body
and this is a place where you know we
will tend to argue
that an engineering approach to the
world is far too simple when you're
talking about complex systems like
like evolved ones like biological
systems
um and that it's um like i said
reductionist
but here even an engineering approach a
uh body as machine
approach which is often far too simple
to actually get you where you need to go
can work if you think of you know a long
bone a
as akin to like a rod of steel well you
bend it and you bend it and you
bend it and obviously you're not you
know you're not you don't have tensile
strength on a long bone
um you know once it it pretty much
shatters
um but it's not going to continue to
retain all of its strength you know
around steel duct
it's not the way a a rod of steel is
somewhat ductile
yes that is that is what i'm and in fact
what you have is um
strength um very much strength in in
in one direction and not not in shearing
direction
but but even with something like steel
with prolonged stress it becomes
weakened
yes and there are all sorts of you know
i don't know how we ended up in
metallurgy territory but um there are
all sorts of interesting
facts about you know two
tubes of steel that look alike can have
very different properties
based on uh things like their internal
shaping and so the shaping of bones has
an impact and the fact that you've
repaired the damage and don't get quite
the same shape back
uh has implications there are also weird
things like
uh tempering steel with heat
that causes you know a realignment of
the molecules that you can't see in the
macroscopic structure but nonetheless
can greatly enhance
strength you can also degrade it with
heat the the analog there in bones is
going to be used
the way you make bones more anti-fragile
as you use them and we don't understand
all of the mechanisms by which that
makes them stronger
some of them are likely to be that it
reforms the inner margins of the bone
and such
there are going to be many other
mechanisms mechanisms that we just don't
know yet but what we do know for sure
is use it and it will become more not
just robust but
more stronger in the face of
stress it's literally anti-fragile and
apologies
uh to nasim to lab if he has used that
example which is highly likely
i'm sure yeah i'm sure he has given the
nature of the model and his mindset but
um in any case in this case you can
actually say well okay bones are
antifragile that's interesting but of
course they're anti-fragile because
you know if you were going to design you
know
we as designers tend to think in terms
of what does that part look like and
then you send it to the factory and they
make it
whereas a part where the factory is
internal to the part and can reshape it
based on
what it turns out happens in the field
right if you're using it and you're
stressing it then the point is oh maybe
it's not strong enough anytime you get
anywhere near the breaking threshold
you're telling the body
actually a little more resource should
be spent here it'll be worth it
and so you know stressing systems causes
them to be made more robust
so i we did we did jump between the the
simple the engineering
model and the more complex biological
model where you know the simple stuff
uh is is going to be less likely to be
anti-fragile
and so you know you put an extreme
stress on a bone
and it's simply going to break and if
you do that multiple times it will
become weaker
so this this anti-fragility model um has
of course bounds yeah okay well
interestingly i think the way you've set
this up makes good sense
because the current predicament with the
vaccines
and there are two of them that are
rapidly moving towards widespread
distribution
shows us both the strength of the
engineering approach and the weakness of
the engineering approach in the context
of a complex system
so in some sense the engineering
approach caused
us to be able to generate and i say us i
mean humanity to be able to generate
vaccines in less than a year
which is a very rapid production
production schedule and you know there
is no
way you should regard this as anything
other than
a spectacular achievement no matter what
else may be true of these vaccines
the ability to get a vaccine that
actually does create
substantial immunity and it looks really
good in this case after
two two vaccinations it looks like 90
percent
successful or close to it in both cases
so that's an amazing achievement
the question is what else does it do and
i want to point to three things
that i believe are worrisome in this
case and that
mean that your normal model your normal
model for how to feel about vaccine
safety
may be good or it may be cruddy or
probably it's somewhere in between
but this doesn't belong in the same
category and
unfortunately because we use these
heuristics
and because there is this voice out
there that for many different reasons
uh some of them purely financial and
some of them uh
policy in policy based uh
there's this voice that sort of wants
you to default into
standard vaccine brain and it's not
appropriate here
so a few episodes ago uh maybe in the q
a
we raised this just briefly and i
reported that i had had a conversation
with a
with a mutual acquaintance who would ask
me you know what what do i do
what do i know and i i at that point it
was just just beginning to emerge
and i did not know that they were mrna
vaccines
and what i said to her and what i said
on air that i had said to her was
it might not be effective but it's
unlikely to be any more dangerous than
any other vaccine
and um i think uh i i think that
is not true um and and i don't know
i think i think we can't know if that is
true how about that
it is possible um that the safety is
even greater
than other vaccines but because um
exactly this technology this is the
first time that it's ever been approved
for use in humans
and because one of the benefits of an
mrna vaccine
is that it doesn't require the virus
itself to develop it
and so it can be developed and
distributed extremely rapidly so it's no
accident that we are seeing two mrna
vaccines as opposed to more traditional
like antigen or protein based vaccines
is precisely because it is one of the
key features of an mrna vaccine
and um the fact is that there are just
there are a couple of things about what
this is doing
that are so novel they aren't inherently
dangerous
but they are inherently novel and we
inherently hold on and we inherently
don't know what happens down that novel
road okay so i wanna
i wanna level us all up here okay
these vaccines and if you frickin
toss us off youtube for speaking literal
careful truth and explaining it then uh
we'll go great guns on this because we
have to stop playing this stupid game
okay
these vaccines are dangerous that does
not mean
they are harmful okay and the
distinction is this
we do not know what the consequence of
these vaccines will be
on a body long term it may be that the
consequence
is not serious harm or that serious harm
comes to a very tiny fraction of people
and it's well worth it
in the context of as you point out the
harm that we
know comes from this virus but
the way to think about this is russian
roulette
is russian roulette dangerous yes it's
[ __ ] dangerous
right but it only harms something like
18
of the people who play around right so
the thing is
it has no harm to most people who
experience it right
and the point is the risk that comes
from pulling the trigger in russian
roulette
is not the same thing as the harm of the
bullet that either
is or isn't in the chamber and so the
distinction is an important one but
that's a dangerous analogy because there
is no benefit to playing russian
roulette well i would agree but my point
is simply about when we say that
something is safe
what does that mean and when we say that
something is safe
what it means is that we know it doesn't
do harm
it doesn't mean that we have not yet
identified a harm
right so all i'm saying is that
the nature of the complex system that we
are interfering with
is such that there are many possible
consequences that we are not in a
position to rule out yet
and because of that i believe we have an
obligation to talk to people
about what the consideration is and as
you point out
you know as we've both pointed out the
harm of covet 19
is very very serious even if the number
the percentage of people who die from it
while they're sick is low right so
it is not as if the fact that there are
big risks that come along
with this vaccine uh is indicative
of something and in fact i think
it's a little hard to say but you know
just eyeballing the technique that they
have used here
in many ways it is
fairly low likelihood of interfering
with the immune system in a disastrous
way
because as you point out there's no
virus involved there's basically
a pseudo virus they've created a
coat a lipid coat and they've got a
segment of
rna and there's there's literally no
infectious agent in the vaccine unlike
traditional vaccines which can
themselves be infectious
infective i'm not actually sure which of
those are the right words here um an
mrna vaccine
is not itself an infectious agent right
so
in some sense what's good about this
vaccine is that you are taking
the so we should describe a little bit
about how it works so you've got
mrna that m is a lower case m and that
means messenger there are different
kinds of rna that do different kinds of
things
mrna is the standard molecule that takes
information from the dna
in your nucleus of your cells transports
it into the cytoplasm of your cells the
part outside the nucleus
and in the cytoplasm there are all of
these rna machines called ribosomes
that take mrnas specifically and they
translate them into proteins which do
all kinds of things
so in this case just as just as
coronaviruses do
we are taking a messenger rna and
injecting it directly
into or injecting it indirectly into the
cytoplasm of these cells
well this big asterisk here yeah which
we'll get back to you
you tell this part of the story then
i'll get back to you so you've got a
basically a lipid fatty layer that
protects the mrna
and this lipid fatty layer joins a cell
and that mrna finds itself in the
cytoplasm of the cell
and the ribosomes discovering this mrna
do exactly what they would do
with an mrna that was transcribed from
the nuclear dna which is that they
translated into protein
so those proteins are the spike protein
of the coronavirus in the absence of the
other components of it
those spike proteins are then found on
the surface
of the cell that has produced them
which makes them visible to the immune
system so
that visibility to the immune system
i'll talk a little bit more about how
immune systems work in a second because
it's kind of
crucial to understand this but the very
fact of a protein that is unfamiliar
showing up on the surface
of familiar cells alerts the immune
system that there is something to be
identified and then the immune system
does its incredible job
which is to learn the
structure of this foreign protein
so that it can recognize it
instantaneously and then the point is if
you get covid
what happens is that spike protein shows
up in the virus and any cells that it
has infected
and your immune system doesn't need to
learn it because it already knows it
right that's the hope
so what were you going to say you had a
caveat the caveat is
uh you get a vaccine in which uh the
injection does not go directly into
the hundred thousand cells i have no
idea if that's even the order of
magnitude that's correct but you know it
doesn't go directly into any cells it
just goes into your bloodstream
yeah and then somehow this mrna has to
get into
the cells and mrna is uh
is very very fragile right it actually
and this is one of the the downsides of
these vaccines is it it decays so
rapidly it has to be kept in incredibly
low temperatures
and somehow it has to be warmed up
sufficiently that you don't get
killed by injection of a you know super
cooled substance into your
into your vein but it has to be it has
to have been warm for such a short
period of time that the mrna didn't
decay
so then it goes into your bloodstream
and somehow it has to get into your
cells before it decays because what is
going on in the intercellular space that
is the space between the cells
in the intercellular space you have a
whole lot of
ribonucleases rnases is how it looks
um when it's spelled out or when it's
just written usually
and what ribonucleases do is that that
ase ending
is the ending that means it's an enzyme
that goes after the thing that it's
named for
and what ribonucleases do which are
intracellular space is filled
with ribonucleases is it destroys rna
okay so how do you get an rna vaccine
that you've just injected into your
bloodstream
into the cells before the ribonucleases
that are in your bloodstream
destroy them well one of the things that
you do is you coat a bunch of these
mrna vaccine particles with this lipid
nanoparticle
which is of course yet another synthetic
thing that you're now putting into your
into your body and we don't know what
the long-term effects are
one thing that i do not know the answer
to but that i am
skeptical that we should be certain that
it's safe
is if there is such a huge
like if there are so many ribonucleases
in the intercellular space
of mammalian cells why do we think that
putting rna into the intercellular space
of a million cells is inherently safe
right what their their selection has
revealed to us by what it is left behind
that it is really important for the
intracellular space of mammals to not
have
active rna in it so it and there are
various possible answers that would be
positive to this question it's possible
that um mrnas for example
that are inside of cells for adaptive
reasons
are lost to the intracellular space when
cells die
and that there's some hazard in that in
other words what's the hazard
well right but the point is if the
hazard comes from
the fact that there's lots of mrna in
cells it gets dumped into this
interstitial space with some regularity
and there's a garbage patrol that cleans
it up because you don't want random
messages translated where they shouldn't
be
right if that's the case then
a vaccine that dumps a small amount of
mrna
into the system and that mrna is able to
get into the cells
may not have an important implication
big if there though
right so and in fact i believe if
if i read this correctly um that these
vaccines actually have a combination of
the naked mrna
and the lipid nanoparticle coded rna
the idea being that one one of the other
of those things is going to work for
some cells and
and it's going to get into enough of
them and you're going to end up getting
you know protection into protein and
then immune response
but there is going to be some naked mrna
um from the vaccine
in the intracellular space that the
ribonucleases will presumably act on
but again i just i don't know
i cannot be 100 confident here right
nobody can
um now maybe that they're experts in
what this is who would be able to take a
pretty good guess on what the net effect
is but again the the real
well except that this is so new well
this is so new and in fact the
here's zach just um put up my screen for
just a second this is a
2016 paper uh from a journal called
therapeutic delivery so
it's a peer-reviewed paper in the
medical research literature called mrna
vaccine delivery using
lipid nanoparticles in which it
describes um
you know what what are the lipid
nanoparticles doing in the last
sentence of the abstract here indeed
lipid nanoparticles can be synthesized
with relative ease in a scalable manner
protect the mrna against degradation
facilitate endosomal escape
can be targeted to the desired cell type
by surface decoration with ligands
and as needed can be co-delivered with a
juventus um
so a ligand is just like a molecule with
a
metal ion in the middle and that's not
quite a sufficient
definition and then in a juvent it turns
out i had to look this one up
is just something that increases the
efficacy of the
of the vaccine and so it's kind of vague
about what the mechanism might be
there's lots of different kinds of
mechanisms
yeah and did you did you encounter in
looking at the mechanisms here
um how specific is this nanoparticle
coat in targeting particular cells and
if so what's what cells are they
targeting
what the lipid nanoparticle is that is
being used is
wait for it proprietary whoa
yeah so we don't know hey look at that
yeah um
okay so what we've got is a technology
that in principle is extremely promising
and for which there is some
reason to imagine that the risks that
are being taken
are smaller than other mechanisms like
inactivated viruses
okay well and we just don't have the
time to get a vaccine using an activated
virus
virus right so what we've got is an
unproven technology
that on paper sounds like it should be
quite safe
but the problem is on paper is not the
same thing as it being safe in a complex
system
especially especially when you are
interfacing
with the adaptive immunity of the host
and that's the thing
is adaptive immunity is the most amazing
process i
so i took uh immunobiology as
an undergraduate it was taught in the
medical school at penn
and it was something i there was no
reason for me to take it
it just sounded really cool right
and i did not have the prereqs but i
took it and it was among the most
stunning courses i ever encountered the
description of what the immune system is
profoundly
altered my understanding of creatures it
under
changed my understanding of evolution
and it still
pays dividends to this day but the the
point is this system
is the most marvelous you know if you
think the eye is marvelous
check out the immune system right it's
even more marvelous
and um what it accomplishes is
spectacular but the
delicateness with which it has to be
balanced in order to do what it does
well without over
achieving and killing you is that is
not a small feat and so anytime you're
interfacing with that system
you're running a whole host of risks
that don't necessarily come from the
small
intervention you made it comes from what
the immune system which has never seen
that intervention before will do with it
right
because in some sense the key to the
immune system is that it
understands anything that isn't you as a
hostile agent and the thing is
that tendency can result in annoyances
like seasonal allergies right we have a
subset of our uh our
b cell immunity that is antibody based
immunity
that reacts to things like pollen
as if they were pathogenic which they're
not and so that you know
overwhelming mucus and all that's a
histamine reaction
that occurs because your body has
misunderstood itself as under attack by
a pathogen
right that's annoying it's under attack
by pollen
right it's under attack by pollen but
likewise you can die of a bee sting
right a bee sting isn't a pathogen
either and your immune reaction to it
can kill you
right anaphylactic shock for example uh
can kill you so
this system when you introduce something
yeah so actually um just
maybe you said this but the distinction
between pathogen and toxin is critical
here yeah
right like um our bodies should respond
to toxins
um by taking them apart as quickly as
possible sure and
we're clearing them inside clearing them
in some way um
if you simply take uh try to take apart
a pathogen well so
a toxin will not tend to be
self-replicating and a pathogen will be
so
excuse me a pathogen that you simply
that the body simply tries to take apart
unless it gets absolutely every single
single instantiation of it
um it will not be uh it will not be a
job that is well done
and you have no protection against
future encounters with that
pathogen right and um so so the body's
response to pathogen versus toxin ought
to be very different it generally is but
the body is sometimes confused when it
runs into toxins
like um whatever the molecule is in in
bee sting right uh or even things that
aren't toxins but are definitely not
self like pollen and treats it like
pathogenic basically it's shunted into
i'm going to respond to this as it's
as if it's an immune threat as if it's a
pathogenic threat right
so you know the the thing is um
these things contain a toxin they don't
contain very much of it and it's not
enough to hurt you on its own but your
own overreaction can kill you and it's
not self-replicating and it's not
pathogenic right
right right so anyway the point is wow
is this an amazing system and it's
keeping you alive right
if your immune system fails boy do you
have a whole host of problems that you
don't even know exist which is one of
the things you know we discovered with
aids and other immunodeficiency
syndromes
right is all of the things that are
being fended off routinely
right so without getting
terribly deep i want to just uh
describe a little bit of the immune
system so that people can understand how
this
vaccine technology could potentially
interact with it badly although again i
think
the technology itself on paper looks
very promising and
less likely to cause um this kind of
harm
than many other technologies which we
have managed the risk for
including traditional vaccines right
including traditional vaccines so
so you are arguing let me just put that
in a in a sound bite you are arguing
that the mrna vaccine has the potential
to actually be safer with regard to
autoimmune response than a traditional
vaccine well
autoimmune response is one thing but
let's just say and we should say this
carefully
it could be that we ultimately discover
that mrna vaccines are the key to
managing
risks that come along with vaccines of
other kinds and that this is a better
technology
that doesn't mean that these current
vaccines are
there right it could be that we discover
something here that then lets us go to
the next generation of these things
which might be
vastly safer so anyway we are at the
very least very low on the adaptive
slope
this is this is so early and so let's
just list the three things that make
this instance of vaccine one that you
should file
separately from other instances of
vaccine and i don't think that what we
do with other vaccines is
is uh very nuanced i think we very
frequently
miss the way to talk about those things
so that we could
actually understand the hazards but um
okay so
the first thing that makes this um of a
separate type
is the novelty of the technology which
we've talked about here
anytime you are going to inject
something into your body that's based on
some
sophisticated nano interaction and
the technology is new you're taking a
massive risk
nobody knows what the the consequences
of it are
safety testing is in fact our only way
to assess that and it hasn't been going
on very long which has to do
with the second thing that puts this so
you got a new technology
you've got rapid development right the
fact that we have got not just of the
technology but of this instantiation of
this technology
right so we've gone from zero to 60 in
2.2 seconds right we've got viable
vaccines which is amazing
whether they're good or not it's amazing
that we've gotten this far
right so novel technology uh
rapid development and the third thing is
that there is um an expectation
of wide scale rapid deployment of these
things in other words there's some limit
to how many of these things can be
produced but people want to get this
stuff into people as quickly as possible
two doses is what's expected
to be necessary to get the full level of
immunity
and they want it to go out to everybody
and frankly they want to prioritize
certain communities and you know get our
frontline health workers vaccinated all
this stuff
and the point is all three of those
things are independent reasons to be
concerned
and all three of those things compound
each other right
so indeed um anyway that's where we are
we're in a situation where there's a
whole lot we don't know
and to the extent and this is actually a
general bias in medicine and all of its
auxiliary fields there's a general bias
to measure short-term harm
and when something does not do
short-term harm to declare it safe
when in fact in many of these cases
there's no way to assess the long-term
harm until a long period of time has
passed
and you know you can appreciate the
dilemma if you have
a pharmaceutical for example that does
some kind of good
you don't want to wait 60 years
you know to give it to people and see
what happens to them in old age if
they've taken it
before you deploy it so you're
inherently taking the risk that it has a
long-term consequence that you don't
know
but it is wrong to say that it's safe if
you don't know what the long-term
consequences are you can say it is safe
in the short term that's the most you
can say
and uh one of the reasons that that is
so dangerous
is that once you have a number
once you have an estimation of safety
something that has been quantified
it's very easy to glom onto that and
imagine that that reflects reality that
that was not just
uh measured correctly but that the thing
that you measured was the correct thing
to measure in the first place
and that second category is actually in
some ways a bigger issue it's really
easy also to focus on oh the data were
bad because
because the measuring is bad we had
researcher error we had you know
whatever machine failure
but did you in fact measure the right
thing in the first place and this is
part of what you're talking about that
you know it's it's
it's very much harder to actually to
take the time and you know we're talking
about
research on which people's careers
depend
and you cannot build a career based on a
50 years in the future we might have a
result um so
for for people who are interested in
pursuing
this question of sort of why applying
metrics and um sort of you know
pseudonumerator innumerate thinking to
things that would appear to be numerate
is is such a problem i recommend so
highly
the short but uh incredibly powerful
book the tyranny of metrics
by uh jerry muller so that's just a
little shout out for that because he
does a terrific job of describing
exactly some of these problems excellent
so yes we are obsessed with short-term
risk
and we tend once we have established
numbers which may be erroneous for other
reasons
um we tend to assume that we know how
safe something is so it's very common
for a doctor
you know if doctor prescribes a drug to
you and you say
uh you know how safe is oh it's a
totally safe drug
it's only been out for five years you
don't know that you can't know that
and to the extent that they will have
some answer it may be well
i mean here's the deeply inside baseball
thing
but we do in order to figure out the
long-term risks and we don't want to
spend a lot of time at it
is we give large doses to animals that
live a short life
and assume that the long-term effects
would show up quickly in them
which is a garbage assumption and the
mice themselves
are uh compromised as people who have
paid attention to the telomere mouse
discussion
um will be well aware so anyway the
garbage assumption
used on garbage model organisms yeah it
might be garbage all the way down
yeah it's a lot of garbage and the idea
that we're
at the point that we discover a
long-term consequence that we don't like
who could have known like of course you
wouldn't have known the specifics but
you could have known you were taking
this risk and that's
that's the point okay so let me quickly
talk about the immune system
so that we can talk about the risk here
um the key thing to understand
is the immune system is built
around a um
an ability to recognize almost any
large organic molecule and
to recognize whether it effectively to
recognize all large organic molecules
that you yourself do not make
so early in development there is a
period of time in which
so you have a diversity of cells b and t
cells and their progenitors that
recognize molecules that fraction that
is triggered by molecules you
yourself are making are eliminated from
the population so what is left over
is that fraction of this large
population of cells hundreds of billions
of cells
that do different things and recognize
different molecules right
the fraction that doesn't react to you
is left over
right and it just hangs out in a kind of
dormant
it circulates and anytime a molecule is
introduced to you that you yourself do
not make
it is very strongly likely to react at
least somewhat with some fraction of
this population a tiny subset of this
large population
of cells and then that cell that has
been triggered by a molecule that you
don't make and the fact that the cell is
triggered tells you it's not a molecule
you make
right that cell then produces a whole
bunch of descendant cells that
have a slightly different formula this
is called clonal selection so
you yourself are an organism that might
live 85 90 years carrying the same
genome and making the same molecules but
you have a subset of cells that evolves
on the scale of hours to days
that gets better and better at
identifying a target an antigen
based on this clonal selection right
it's an amazing
fact how old is this what did they mean
when did this form of the immune system
evolve do we know
when did it evolve yeah or i'm sure we
know but do you know
i'm about to take a huge risk with my
reputation and say that i
think i think it goes back to our common
ancestor with salamanders
you think it's tetrapods yes okay not
vertebrates so that was so
that if that is true you were saying
that you know salmon don't have this
kind of immune response
but any of the the descendants of
the first vertebrates that came onto
land do yes now this worries me
because that seems like it can't
possibly true be true because what do
you do
with a very long-lived animal some
sharks are incredibly long-lived
large-bodied how do they avoid being
parasites do they have a
progenitor of this clonal selection
phenomenon have i misunderstood it is it
vertebrates that have it
but any long-lived large-bodied organism
is very likely to encounter pathogens
that
invade it and adaptive immunity would be
a key way to go after well there are
obviously there are different ways to do
it they're long-lived organisms
like redwood trees they have it eating
they have it easy
because they've got things like
segregation of the germline
and no they don't have a segregation i
mean i mean they
sorry they lack a segregated germline
but they also um because they
effectively have
total potency in their cells they can
they can just drop pieces of themselves
they're not modular they can kill them
off
so you know there's no part of a redwood
tree
that you couldn't turn off if it got
infected so you can have a big
you know wound that just goes dead it
kills itself off to protect the rest of
the tree
you can't do that if your liver goes
dead you're cooked so and and no
vertebrate
there there are there are a few
vertebrates actually a few salamanders
that um
can lose a limb and grow one back but i
don't think it's actually understood to
be in response to infection i think it's
if if damaged
if oh i don't think we've ever seen it
as a response to infection it's just if
damaged
um you end up with a new hand the only
time i've seen it it was in response
to having put two species of salamanders
in the same aquarium
that didn't get along as well as i was
hoping
you gotta tell the story i don't think i
know this um yeah i put uh
northwest so you're a kid at this point
no what is this
i'm i guess i'm a professor at evergreen
oh my god
uh so i took northwest salamanders okay
so these are
ambestoma and uh tariqa granulosa the
uh rough skin okay so pretty distantly
related to from two different families
of salamanders totally different i took
them from the same
pond so i sort of thought oh this would
be cool they'll get along well enough
and the um that tarika went after the
ambition didn't it
went after the limbs off of all of them
uh i'm trying to remember it was
multiple limbs
i may have separated them at some point
but um
but in any case yes the uh the the um
the
northwest the northwest salamander lost
its limbs to the
um to the the rough skin new ruskin newt
being the most
uh toxic pound-for-pound creature on
earth or at least
arguably so yeah um and then the limbs
started to regenerate which
you saw the budding happen oh it was
absolutely amazing stunning
you know we were married and had kids at
this point i don't remember the story
somehow you kept this you didn't want to
tell me
[Laughter]
yes somehow you probably you know still
remember the theme to the brady bunch
though i'm sure you never watched it or
maybe you watched an episode but you
don't remember this because
it's been crowded out by i don't know
covet or evergreen or who knows
um okay back to the story yeah
you've got a system wait yeah tarika
newts also salamanders
cannot regrow their limbs so this
ability to regrow limbs is actually
limited i think to the ambition
um very very small group of of tetrapods
and um so anyway most the vast majority
of uh even vertebrates cannot do that
so anyway some questions i'll be curious
to know whether sharks have adaptive
immunity and i've
yeah misunderstood or something but
anyway i think
it goes back at least to salamanders if
i remember correctly but anyway you've
got this adaptive immunity system
it's predicated on the ability to
distinguish self from non-self the way
it does that is it has a population of
cells that only responds to non-self
and that thing waits for any molecule it
doesn't recognize
and then it mounts a response to it and
so vaccines the way they work
is you dump something into the system
that carries molecules that you yourself
do not make
something that has been rendered
harmless or nearly harmless
the immune system sees it regards it as
a pathogen
learns the formula and then when you get
sick with the actual thing
the immune system is primed to react and
it reacts so quickly that you don't
detect sickness right same reason that
you don't get sick
twice from a lot of things you don't get
sick after the vaccine because you've
been
pseudo sick with molecules that it's
like a wanted poster
in the in the post office that alerts
you to somebody dangerous so you know
them right away
they don't have to harm you for you to
discover that they're the enemy
right okay so
um the way this uh you're looking for a
prop
well i don't know if it's worth
the image but just since these uh terms
are so frequently
used
i think i have this backwards i do
but i can't draw upside down
so you got this this is an antibody
shape and it is actually the shape
of a number of other things too
receptors uh
on the surface of t cells but this is a
basic antibody
right it's y shaped and it's got this is
called a heavy chain
it's heavy because it's long this is a
light chain it's like because it's short
and then there are always two light
chains uh two light chains and two heavy
chains and they have this y shape and
then up at the tip here
you have a variable region so all of
this stuff is basically standard tool
kit right that's the frame of the bike
that just holds the parts together
the rubber meets the road here at the
variable
regions and these variable regions are
highly variable and each cell produces
a specific antibody and when that cell
is triggered to produce more
cells like it there's variation between
them in these variable regions and these
regions
just kind of stick to anything that they
have the right formula for
uh just a point of order since uh you
used an analogy that if anyone else had
used it i would just accept it but
you saying the the most of this
is like the frame of the bike that just
holds the parts together yeah
you have actually designed and built
your own bike yes
um not just bought a frame and put parts
on it you have actually done
the you know the brazing and the tig
welding dig welding
uh no i didn't i did brazil you know
just just the brazing
um so you know that actually all frames
of bikes aren't the same
and you said that as if so is do you
really mean this is like
the frame of a bike and they're all a
little bit different but it doesn't
really matter because
the real functional stuff is at the
sides or is that actually not
i said it because the purpose of a frame
is to hold the parts
on the frame itself doesn't do anything
what it does is it holds the parts in
the right orientation and distance apart
but it also holds the rider in the right
orientation sure but i mean you know the
seat
you're not really touching the frame as
you ride so anyway the the point really
is this is a structural
thing and you know the tail has a
they're a bunch of different kinds of
antibodies and the tails
do different things and whatever but the
basic point is
from the point of view of recognizing
hostile entities
it's this variable region up at the tip
of the antibodies
and the t cells so b cells make
antibodies b cells also have receptors
that look like antibodies on their
surface which is how they know whether
or not they've been triggered and
make more of themselves t cells don't
make any free flowing antibodies
but they do have receptors like this on
their surface
and they do things they're various
different kinds of t cells but anyway
there's the specific
immunity the adaptive immunity this
evolving
army of cells that adapts to the
particular pathogen
that is responsible for you being so
free of pathogens right
it's really good at finding cells that
are infected and killing them
uh finding free-flowing uh pathogens and
killing them
and you know as long as it's good at
recognizing the difference between self
and non-self
and not overreacting then this all just
happens passively in the background and
occasionally you get sick enough with
something that it takes you two weeks to
get the formula but by and large you're
not
sick right the problem is
if you think about it imagine if a
pathogen gets into your system right it
doesn't look like you molecularly so
this system reacts to it right and it
starts
uh killing it off well there's variation
in these pathogens too they're evolving
right those that are most easily
recognized by the immune system
are most vulnerable right those that
look
least like that are least recognizable
are least vulnerable and so there's
selection for those that are not easily
found by the immune system right so
there's selection inside your body
and you're trying to adapt quickly
enough to spot the thing
and it's adapting uh hey it's a
hemipteran
it is adapting to escape the immune
system right now the problem is
that because this system reacts to
anything
that looks not like you but it doesn't
react to things that look like you
there's selection for pathogens to look
like you right molecularly
all right so that's the game that we are
interfering with here and hopefully we
are interfering in a way
in which the pathogen is too far from
looking like you
and the vaccine doesn't disrupt the
self-nonself recognition system in a
massive way but
the number of things that can go wrong
with this is many so
you mentioned autoimmune disorders i
think it's one of the things that ought
to be on our list
right what is our list of what of
hazards here what might show up
if we did have 10 20 30 years of
data on what happens to people who get
this vaccine
and i mean already i've seen i can't
pull it up i don't remember where but
news reports suggesting
that people with a lot of allergies
should
use caution and consider not taking
these vaccines which which strikes me as
exactly
squarely on target of what you're
talking about right so what we get from
that
is we know that this is having an
unpredictable effect
based on individual variation in
immunity right
and we don't like the type of immune
response the strength and
speed of immune response within your
body right and we don't know why
because typically you know a lot of
vaccines can cause an anaphylactic
reaction in people who are sensitive to
them but typically it has to do with
something like the eggs that they were
grown in have a lot of
proteins and for some reason your immune
system
sees one of these proteins as much more
dangerous than it actually is and it
amounts to an immune response that can
then
jeopardize your life right so we don't
know why something as simple as this
is triggering uh anaphylactic
shock or the potential for it but the
fact that in some people that's
happening says oh this is having an
unpredictable effect with some immune
systems right what other unpredictable
effects might it have with some immune
systems
we don't know yet because it ain't been
around long enough for us to
even just detect all of these patterns
and then we have another
um indication of a kind of harm
which showed up this week and this one
it's interesting because you can see how
the narrative
is being shaped around it which is hey
zach can you show um
the uh bell's palsy
um the there's a pdf i sent you
okay can you scroll down i'm not gonna
read it on that screen
scroll down to where i highlighted it
keep going
there it is okay that paragraph okay so
what this says
i i won't put you through all of it but
safety data from approximately
38 000 participants
um who were more than 16 years
old randomized one to one that means 20
000 a little less than 20 000 got
the actual vaccine the others got a
placebo
with two months follow up after the
second dose suggests a favorable safety
profile and then they go through
what the reactions that they saw were
it's a very standard list for the most
part
they saw some fatigue some headaches
muscle pain some chills some joint pain
fever none of that is all that surprised
severe adverse reactions occurred in
zero to four point six percent of
participants which is a weird number why
is that a range why is it a range why is
that a reaction why is that a range
okay but then the highlighted section
says
among non-serious unsolicited
adverse events there was a numerical
imbalance of four
cases of bell's palsy in the vaccine
group compared to no cases in the
placebo
placebo group though the four cases in
the vaccine group do not represent a
frequency above that expected in the
general population
so this news got out people didn't know
what to make of it but now the fact is
we can actually interpret what they've
said here pretty clearly
so can you show the um the diagram of
bell's palsy
that i sent you the the um cartoon
okay so bell's palsy involves some
facial
symptoms in which one side of the face
droops
the forehead uh is de-wrinkled
by uh by the bell's palsy it is the
result of something going on with a
facial
nerve and its uh cause is still
unknown so you've got four cases
in this group now bell's palsy a isn't a
permanent condition in general it clears
up
b um there is some
frequency of it um i think it's
something like one in ten thousand
people is expected to encounter it
to have it as a symptom in any given
year
on average so these groups the test
group and the control group in this case
were 20
000 people but for much less than a year
and so what they've said is
actually this bell's palsy might just be
the background bell's palsy that you
would expect
but conspicuously the four cases that
they've got
showed up in the treatment group not the
control group
now the point is this is all so small i
want to see bigger numbers before i know
what to make of that that's exactly it
this could easily be a case where
there's a surprising amount of bell's
palsy in this short period of time it
just
accidentally shows up in your treatment
group and it has nothing to do with it
that could easily be the case with
numbers this small
on the other hand the pattern is
conspicuous right they've got a short i
mean but i mean this this is what
statistics is for
exactly and i've never i mean that's the
first time i've seen i don't even know
what exactly what document we were
looking at but
um those would be easy statistics to do
even even i know what statistics to do
on that if i had the background rate for
the population
and their data well but we know what it
is that they concluded
if we assume that they did the math
right we know what they concluded we
know what they said but they didn't show
any statistics which means that they
made a conclusion
based on yeah it looks fine no no as
opposed
no i don't think that's right i think
they did the stats and what they came up
with
is that this is a pattern but it's not
statistically significant
right so uh can you show that i would
hope if i were reviewing that paper
before you know if i were a peer
reviewer of that paper
i would have said uh this claim is
unsubstantiated show me you know show me
the test you used and
so that was not a peer-reviewed paper
right that was an internal fda
document evaluating the risk and you
know they have to be able to do this
they've got to be able to get people
into a room and say what have we seen
what do we think the chances are that it
means anything
okay so they do all that there's nothing
wrong with them having done that and
there's nothing wrong with them saying
this is not a statistically significant
trend but
by can you show the snopes uh
debunk is stopes debunking the fda here
no snopes is debunking can you put that
on the live screen
snopes is debunking the widely
circulated claims of bell's palsy likely
being
caused by this vaccine
can you scroll up
that's scrolling down okay
we will talk about whether that's
scrolling up or scrolling down
um oh so this
i'm unclear on if i misread something
but anyway it says uh
out of more than 20 000 patients who
took pfizer's trial vaccine for covet 19
uh four developed um bell's palsy
so it's true that four out of more than
twenty thousand patients although i
don't get how they get more than twenty
thousand but anyway
um four out of more than twenty thousand
patients developed it
but we don't know if the vaccine caused
it that's that looks right
yeah um i mean if assuming that this
is based on that fda paper that you just
showed which i have seen exactly what
everyone watching has seen in this case
it's right uh
and i i am not sure whether something
changed about this that's a live link
or whether i misread it when i first
looked at it can you show the other url
uh sees no causal relationship right
so cdc will monitor for bell's palsy
among pfizer vaccine recipients but sees
no
causal relationship now
this is something that has to be
understood as
a scientist would evaluate it what we've
got
is a clear trend four to zero
between the treatment group and i would
be real careful i wouldn't call that a
clear trend
well it is it is it is statistically not
significant
because sample size is clearly a
disparity in
the incidence of bell's policy between
the vaccine and the
and the placebo group trend suggests
something um that we
that we just don't have enough
information to say yeah yeah
i agree with you better way to say it is
a discrepancy uh or a disparity between
uh the two and it is significant enough
uh
informally speaking to monitor it it is
not significant enough to infer
a causal relationship because the sample
sizes are small and if the sample sizes
were larger
that is to say more people and longer
time
then we would either this pattern to the
extent that there
is a pattern would disappear because
it's actually the result
of sampling error or
it would be reinforced if it is causal
but this is the reason that you need
large
data sets and we don't have it and part
of that is because we just don't have a
lot of time so this is reflective
of we are rapidly
racing to deploy this vaccine uh which
means that this is all happening
uh you know for for good reason for
excellent reasons right i mean the
not not only are there long-term health
effects from getting covered 19 among
those who survive not all of them but
among many of those who survive
um but globally the economy is tanking
yeah small businesses are just you know
this this is unimaginable and how a huge
number of sectors of
not just the us but uh the world's
economies
recover from this is frankly impossible
to imagine
and every week that this goes on it
becomes harder and harder to take
ourselves out of the hole yes this is a
disaster at
many different levels and what i want to
see us do
is have a proper adult conversation
about the fact that we have
much greater than normal risk for a
vaccine because we have
much less information on the
consequences of this vaccine
and we have a bigger crisis both at the
level of society grinding to a halt and
not knowing how to deal
with the uh um with distributing
the arbitrary costs of the pandemic
fairly or whatever it has to do and we
have a virus that does a tremendous
amount of bodily damage to people
circulating in an uncontrolled way so
there's lots of reason that you might
take and in fact should be willing to
take more than the average level of risk
but pretending that that doesn't exist
here is in my opinion
unconscionable right and so the last
thing i want to say
is we are constantly caught in this bind
you and i have talked about it
on the podcast several times before
between
the public health level analysis and the
individual health level analysis
and the lying in order to make the
public health level analysis
turn into the individual level analysis
is the problem
yeah so to make this clear for people
who don't know what we're talking about
imagine for a second that you had let's
take covet out of the
scenario let's imagine that you had a
deadly disease and a vaccine that
created high levels of immunity to it
with substantial
risk or maybe even substantial harm
let's say you know one in ten thousand
people had a
crippling reaction and
you wanted to deploy this because the
harm of the disease outweighed that
one in ten thousand people who was
crippled but you were going to [ __ ]
somebody who might have
well not gotten the disease or been okay
with it
so you're doing serious harm that you've
got to account for
in that case imagine the analysis
of the last person on earth to get the
vaccine imagine you could
magically produce the vaccine you
produce enough doses and you get it to
everybody
the last person on earth to take that
vaccine
has no reason to take the risk right
because everybody else is vaccinated the
circulating levels of the disease will
be low and there's no reason for them to
take the risk
okay you can then back that analysis off
the second or last person
has the same analysis and then there's
some point no it's not the same
with every every person before that has
a bit more reason yes there's a
conclusion for the second
to last person would be the same but the
calculation would be very slightly
different no i would say that the
conclusion is very slightly different in
the calculation
the calculation itself is the same but
the result of the calculation is
slightly different and therefore the
conclusion is slightly different which
is to say
if you are the last person on earth not
vaccinated there is no reason for you to
take it
if you are now one of two people and who
are not vaccinated and you're next
there is some reason to take it but it's
minuscule and
when i say conclusion i just mean up or
down right
i'm taking it or i'm not taking it they
both reach the same conclusion if
they're
rationally deducing so how many people
do you go back
right before you start to get into
territory um
that looks like well individuals and
here's
like individuals might well be wanting
to make different decisions
than right the governments who are
looking out for their entire populations
would make for them so if everybody's
doing the calculation
for their individual well-being you've
got a category
based on how late they are in the
sequence in which it's clear that it's
not worth the risk
you've got a category in which
reasonable people could disagree
and then you've got a category in which
the risks of the disease outweigh
the risks of the vaccination
substantially enough that every
reasonable person should go with it
so then you get people jockeying for
position
now the point that i want to make is
a we've got a problem with anti-vaxxers
because some fraction of anti-vaxxers
are
in a so the category of people who
doesn't want to take the vaccine
right so when you say anti-vaxx are you
just talking about anti-anti-cop19
vaccines or just the whole the bigger
i wouldn't call those anti-vaccines say
that there's an anti-vaccine trying to
be clear and some fraction of it
are effectively free riders right so
what we have just described is a free
rider problem in which
people who are late in the sequence get
the benefit of everybody else's being
vaccinated without paying the cost of
their own risk
it's a very rational decision to make
it's unfair but it's rational from the
point of view of the individual
and so part of what we get the vax the
anti-vaxxers versus
the vaccine triumphalists is about
the triumphalists are trying to sell the
idea that these things are safe and
they're for anybody who
talks about safety as a crazy person
there's no reason to pay any attention
to anybody in the anti-vaxx
group right that thing
is really a cryptic free rider versus
collective action
question like so many things are right
the collective action problem
uh might have a an analysis that says
everybody
takes their share of the risk and we all
get the benefit of the immunity and
nobody gets an exemption unless there's
a medical reason for it
so just to be clear you're saying that
this is actually what the two camps
are even though the cover story and
indeed the conscious belief of many
people in both camps does not match
those conclusions i don't want to say
that this is what that debate is because
i think there's a ver
there's a variety of ways that people
find themselves
in these well that's my point that
regardless of what your cover story is
regardless of who you talk to and the
way you talk
about it um that it is effectively um
sort of uh this is this is a public
health analysis uh
versus a we have to we have to stamp out
the free riders
right so it's a yeah it's a it's a free
rider problem in disguise
um and the other thing the
the bitter pill of this analysis is
if you are going to wag your finger at
safety skeptics of vaccines right
then what you have to do is rig the
system
the safety system so that it is biased
in the direction of caution
right and a safety system in which
you've got for-profit companies
that have partially or completely
captured the
uh safety mechanism right that is not a
safe system and so what in effect we
have done
is we have fueled the free riders
however they come to us and whatever
arguments they deploy
because in fact they have a better point
with respect to safety than they ought
to
and that comes in two forms one safety
isn't nearly as good as we claim it is
it could be better and we have not made
it better in part
because of uh um financial
considerations which
should you know we should neutralize we
should use our governmental apparatus to
neutralize the perverse incentives for
the companies that are making these
things
so that the things are as safe as
possible and then when we
effectively dictate that people have to
take the risk for our collective
well-being
we've minimized the risk right that
would be the responsible thing to do
but the other reason that they have more
of a point than they should
is that we are not honest about the
costs and benefits because we
basically treat people like children and
we basically
pretend that these things are safe and
that anybody who believes otherwise
is you know effectively claiming that
there are
lizard people we fuel that movement
right right um so yes anyway i think
that's
pretty much uh where we needed to go
here
right you've got a complex system we're
intervening
in with it in ways that could create
autoimmunity we don't know that it does
we know that this having at least
uh you know one effect and maybe two
effects
that we didn't expect um you know
possibly bell's palsy and it seems like
anaphylactic
reactions that we didn't see coming um
and hopefully and these are the known
short-term effects from
groups of from a group of 20 000 people
yeah known
very short term and so and a tiny
fraction of the number of people who
will ultimately be vaccinated with these
vaccines
right exactly and so i guess the last
thing to say is
were we going to be adult about this and
have a proper conversation
there would be at least the question
of is there some scheme that
distributes our collective risk better
than
simply rushing every doctor
nurse and other person who works on the
front lines into this program in other
words
do you want to hold half those people
back or a quarter of them
you know why i'm not saying that i
expect anything to happen to everybody
who's vaccinated here i don't in fact i
think this technology is really
promising but
i wouldn't want to take the risk with
all of them that seems
really can we afford to um have deeply
compromised our entire health care force
three years down the road right no we
cannot right so
anyway what is the scheme in which you
hedge the risk of this
with some sort of contingency backup
plan that doesn't completely upend us
if it turns out there's something going
on here we don't see coming right yeah
that's really the the question yeah
well okay that's our uh
that's our will we get canceled
conversation for today yep um i think
we've been at it for a very long time
already so we should save the discussion
of journalism
and my observations about how people
drive and what i think it means about
their politics
for next time but i do want to say just
a couple words about sexy flies
just finish with that all right can i do
that i'm sitting down all right so
the journal animal behavior this month
december 2020 published
an article that found that male flies
um are uh differently attractive
to female flies this is drosophila
melanogaster
standard model organism that um
mostly in genetics that is not so far as
i know nearly so compromised as those
mice but
but who knows okay so when i took uh
population genetics in santa cruz i was
very lucky to take population genetics
with
uh one of the world's great population
geneticist bill rice
and he he worked on flies and
um mostly genesis do of course it's a
great organism and we know a lot about
it and anyway it's it's uh
it's been a a standby but anyway he
joked that
for the population geneticist going out
into nature to get study organisms
involved going over the trash can
and collecting the flies that were that
were flying around the banana peels or
whatever been thrown in there
i thought that was funny yeah and these
these are fruit flies they're not
you know they're not like horse flies or
black flies it's they're they're
shoe flies that's right um
okay so um we know from
from previous research uh that
female drosophila female flies strongly
prefer
males who have longer bigger wings to
males who have more rounded wings
and we are also finding that wing shape
is affected by diet
and so it's not simply uh some males
have
the the alleles for longer and bigger
wings and
those are the alpha males there's the
studly males and some wings have
rounder wings and too bad for them nope
it's affected by diet
and presumably better diets result in
the sexier wings
well what makes it better so
um so the diet so they they have these
five strains of flies and they actually
this is i think it was like 15 years so
they've got five
five strains of flies on five different
diets for a long time that's a very long
time in flight time because they have
such short generation times
so they've got a standard drosophila
diet of cornmeal and then they fed some
apple some banana some carrot and some
tomato
okay so they've got these five different
strains of
flies apples carrots carrots
and tomato and cornmeal so five
different
uh flies you have any idea who who do
you think was the sexiest
tomato yeah did i nail it you did hell
yeah
and i have really nothing to say about
why that might be and you just got you
know you
nailed the 20 there i have a sense that
the tomato
is chemically quite a bit more diverse
than anything else on that list
why what is what is that about well a
it's a nightshade and so
it's bound to have some uh fancy
alkaloids in it um okay so let's let's
just go there for a moment so
cornmeal um probably okay all five of
these
are going to have been strongly human
selected by agriculture apple banana
carrot tomato cornmeal all of them right
um corn and i know the least about what
we've done to carrots
um but corn banana and apple we have
certainly
selected strongly um to take out all the
secondary metabolites
that would at least for humans cause any
distress
and i don't know if that if we would
share the metabolic pathways with flies
that would cause them to stress
but those are certainly the easiest to
digest of those five
five plants for us carrots i just
know less about but that's interesting
you say you know tomato
is a nightshade like potatoes like
eggplant
and nightshades we have not managed to
select
out of nightshades uh some of the
toxicity
yeah and you were saying that
effectively almost
almost like the tiny kernel of truth and
homeopathy
right the little bit of of toxicity
um can potentially create yeah i want to
be careful with that tiny truth in
homeopathy because of course in
homeopathy that tiny truth may be
exactly equal to zero right but um
but but some some tiny little insult can
actually
um create create a stress that can then
create a kind of anti-fragility perhaps
that can
that can make stronger yeah i don't
actually know what i'm responding to
because on the one hand you might expect
that the tomato would be
um you might expect it to be extreme and
couldn't predict you might have like a
two-tailed hypothesis like it's going to
either be the best of the worst flies
but i'm not sure which
yeah or it selects against the uh
yeah i could see it going a lot of ways
i'd love to know more about exactly what
happened but
it's also possible there's just a
greater diversity of molecules
in tomatoes than anything else on that
list and
that results in what i'm inferring is
that
if in effect the wing shape is revealing
to the females that a male is very well
fed
which according to the hypothesis i
deployed
in my dissertation would suggest that
all of the things that her offspring
might get
from that male she's only getting genes
all of those things are
spelled properly spelled well and
coordinate well with each other
right so any male who does really well
in finding food
is likely not to be heavily compromised
in any heritable way
and so well if there's if if it were at
that level you might expect positive
assertive mating for diet i don't
actually think the article says
what the females are raised on but they
should have raised the females
also on each of these five diets
and then you know given carrot females
to you know tomato males and
all the i agree with you that that would
be an interesting question and there are
other systems that i think work like
that
but um in this case if a female was just
assessing
how um nutritious a diet a male had
managed
to find for himself she's evaluating how
his wings look
because only on a really good diet do
the wings end up taking their full
beautiful form
listen to me talking about flies this
way um flies who eat tomatoes are
sexiest brett
sexiest sexiest doesn't make him sexy i
didn't say that okay but
um so in any case it might be that he's
just evaluating how good was his diet
because a male
in the wild a male whose diet was
excellent is probably
really well constructed in every way she
should care about which wouldn't require
her to be on the same diet
true yeah right but but if it's if she
is
assessing uh localness for instance
right right
then you would expect positive assertive
mating for diet because that's a really
good indicator of how local you are did
you eat the same thing i did
uh then you probably had access to the
same stuff sure yeah
um and you know otherwise maybe we get
xenophobic flies
and mate choice that's pretty much it we
don't know for sure the tomato diet
created the sexy wings but
those males who ate tomatoes were the
sexiest awesome
yeah all right i will keep that in mind
yeah it's also possible that i was
inferring it was the tomato because just
anecdotally tomatoes are more likely to
have flies around them
and that i somehow subconsciously picked
up that fact
but i don't know that's true i would say
bananas are very common yeah i mean i
think
um tomatoes will decay on your counter
more quickly than a banana or an apple
will and most people would keep
their cornmeal you know in a sealed
container we would keep our cornfield in
the seal container and our carrots in
the refrigerator et cetera
and don't tend to let fruit we have
occasionally let tomatoes get to that
spot get to that stage and very rarely
let any of the rest
of these things get to that stage the
stakes were made they were not by the
flies no
no um all right are we there i think
we're there
all right um so i guess we have where is
the end of this
um we have the usual end of
end of stream announcements then all
right if i can find the end of my notes
here
all right um
yes you can go to
store.darkhorsepodcast.org as you see on
the screen there
if you're interested in darkhorse
merchandise
you can email thedarkhorse.moderator
gmail.com
moderator for any logistical questions
like how do i pose a question when is
the private q a
the answer to that we will tell you
right now is in about 15 minutes
for now we only have it here on youtube
um i'm beginning to hear from people who
say
since since we began doing this people
have been saying why don't you make the
q a part of the podcast like why don't
you also
upload that and i think it's just so
much more casual
that and it would it feels like it would
gum up the the podcast that we don't
want to do that but
there are some people who are saying i
really don't want to be on youtube at
this point i don't want to i don't want
to participate in the youtube universe
at all
is there any other place you could put
up your q a we don't have anything that
we're working on in that regard but we
are hearing
the concerns as we also have the
concerns for being completely dependent
on the big
tech platforms um
you can join either of our patreons get
access at mine to the private q
a every month um to yes
and actually i do need to make an
announcement about this i forgot yes
um there was an it's my
error but there's a flaw in the way
patreon is structured
that resulted in some of the people who
are supposed to get an invite for the
uh coalition of the reasonable
discussion not having gotten
the invite and so i'm going to do a
makeup conversation
for anybody who didn't get the invite or
anybody who
did get the invite but wasn't able to
make it to that discussion
um so that the timing will be announced
but
if you didn't get your invite or you
weren't able to make it
please let us know at support
brettweinstein.net brett has one tea
um there's a second one in weinstein
brett has one tea
weinstein has the backup tee
right in the middle um
so anyway yes if you uh want to
participate in
the makeup conversation or i suppose if
you are
signing up late uh i could grandfather
you in for that one but
anyway contact us at that address and
let us know and we will set up a time
um i think if you're signing up late and
you get access your grandchilding them
in
wow yeah all right okay i'm gonna have
to
meditate on that yeah so um
lots of good stuff going on those
patreons including access the discord
server where there
are apparently a whole lot of other
conversations going on
and we're going gonna take a 15-minute
break and then come back to answer your
questions picking up a few from
last episode uh a number of your super
chat questions from this hour
and then uh picking up super chat
questions that you begin to ask next
hour
uh in the order that they come in so we
look forward to seeing you then
yes um and if you will not be there for
the q a
continue to have an excellent hanukkah
and keep your immune system
targeted on non-self all alright
we'll see in 15.
you